the tyrants of the monster verse are
gigantic prehistoric super species that
possess the powers that defy the laws of
physics amongst these tyrants the most
well-known is Godzilla of course and
then the other big four which is calm
Rodan Mothra and Ghidorah
unfortunately Gamera and gears and
destoroyah hath not made their debut in
legendaries most of us as for now
whereas new monsters have made their
first ever appearance in Godzilla king
of the monsters movie and they are
Scylla Methuselah and behemoth while we
have made an earlier video about these
size comparison of these monsters they
were just guesstimates and not official
sizes but now legendary have released
their official stats and well the
numbers will surprise you here we go
let's start with Scylla she is a giant
armored cephalopod with black coloration
and six very long bony and lightly head
lengths each with two joints and ending
with a claw with small spikes growing
out of the first joints it also has a
plated mantle with ten tendrils and a
pair of black eyes Scylla looks like a
squid spiral like Titan which was
dormant until Ghidorah woke her up and
did his bidding Scylla will also kill
sailors near land or water or whenever
they are near her the official size of
this tyrant is Trier and 41 feet tall
which is almost as tall as 2014 Godzilla
although its weight has not yet been
given next let's discuss Titanus
Methuselah very little as seen of him on
screen this creature appears to be
quadrupedal with mammalian face
possessing horns like a bull his eyes
lack visible pupils and a glassy and a
bit whitish or clouded over
Methuselah most noticeable physical
trait is the gigantic mountain he
carries on his back which allows him to
blend into the landscape surrounding his
place of rest in germany he also can
disguise himself as an island or an
iceberg well he kinda resembles a mix of
Anguirus Gamera and the pokemons
Torterra
specifically the latter as we suspect
the designs to be similar since detector
Pikachu Totoro was also a legendary
movie Moana classifies Methuselah as a
protected tyrant along with Godzilla
Mothra and behemoth in the past he has
shielded and even transported groups of
humans from natural disasters and Titan
attacks Methuselah can camouflage
himself as a mountain apparently very
quickly what is surprising is that this
Titan was not 400 feet tall as earlier
estimated it was shorter than even
Scylla at 322 feet tall so now we come
to the fan favorite the half mammoths
slots tied and caught behemoth behemoth
was originally conceptualized as a giant
mammoth with tusks on his lower jaw
similar to add a new theorem and would
like protrusions on its legs eventually
this design was discarded in favor of
making the creature more like a giant
sloths
although the mammoths like tusks were
retained he knuckle walks like an ape
using his long and muscular four limbs
which are larger than his legs behemoths
most notable trade are his colossal
mammoths light tusk which juts downwards
from his cheeks and he also has brown
fur and is said to be fireproof
behemoths can use his strong and sharp
tusks to destroy buildings with ease he
can also attack with the claws on his
fore limbs while standing on his hind
legs behemoths movement leaves behind
trace amounts of radiation which as a
result can grow jungle like foliage on
his path therefore curing or even
sustaining the environment one
noticeable example of his was when clear
portions of the Amazon rainforest spawn
due to behemoths radiation amongst the
new tyrants he is the biggest standing
around 350 4 feet tall which is the same
as 2014 Godzilla we were a bit surprised
at these stats since we have always
thought Methuselah to be the biggest and
maybe even the heaviest tyrant but in
fact he is the smallest or maybe just
the shorter of the three at 322 feet or
98 point 14 meters coming in lower than
even Scylla
which is 341 feet or a hundred and four
meters tall we earlier said that Scylla
might have been about 300 feet tall
which would be the size of the female
Mewtwo
so standing face to face against the
king of the monsters Methuselah's tip of
the back would be at the shoulder of
godzilla and his head would be at
Godzilla's crotch socket now behemoth
will be 40 feet shorter than Godzilla or
starting just below his chin it would be
interesting to see both of these tyrants
face one another but that might not
happen as we now have Godzilla versus
calm and maybe mecha King Ghidorah or
maybe make a Godzilla coming into the
next movie as the second villian anyway
we have now come to the end of the video
please subscribe for more of these
monster content right here on mine cue